hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought a big piece of land and are
prototyping a more sustainable way of
living
not sure how it's gonna go but let's see
and in the previous video you've seen us
dragging out a lot of old trees and
chopping down some young ones
basically gathering big piles of wood
and
in today's video we're gonna chop them
down and we could borrow a wood chipper
from the municipality
so we have our neighbor friends coming
with a tractor to go to the municipality
to pick it up and then come here to
start shopping
[Music]
so yeah we got a few startup issues
something is stuck in there and the wood
we are chopping first is right here from
the little swamp we cleaned a few weeks
ago
and once the machines was cleaned up
we're ready to go
[Applause]
[Applause]
and the chopping is going quite smooth
most of these are dead trees
and once it was all done we had a nice
pile of chips
[Applause]
it feels really nice like a new raw
material to use
now this is done and we're going to the
next spot which is base camp
[Applause]
so
we broke the belt
so the guys drove it to the repair shop
quick simple fix and the next day we're
ready again
and now we're gonna do the van area from
last week's update
and here we have actually a lot of trees
to chop so it's time to get serious
time to go into bunny mode
[Applause]
and this machine is quite loud i mean we
use headphones all the time
and we offer them some as well but they
didn't really want it i wonder actually
what kind of beep they have in their
ears at the end
of the day anyway it's quite a
repetitive task but it's actually nice
to do
it really feels like you're cleaning up
all these trees and creating this nice
pile of chips it suddenly feels very
useful this material
and once the vent area was ready we
needed to go to the last part
all the trees we took out when we
cleaned the lake in update 13
and this is a lot
[Applause]
and we had some problems with the
machine again one advice i got from them
you don't borrow your wife and your
machines
yeah yeah i guess that is the
consequence of borrowing other people's
tools
but nothing our farmers friends can't
[Applause]
fix
and as you can see the wood chips of
this pile look different
much bigger it's because this contained
much younger trees
and finally the job was done woodchipper
goes back to the municipality and we
have our wood chips
we have a pile of wood chips over here
another pile over here
a big pile over here and a massive pile
of wood chips right here
yeah and these wood chips are actually
super useful because they help you to
clean up your old trees
but also give you chips to make pathways
and you can use them for mulching when
you grow vegetables
so i really enjoyed making these wood
chips
and in the long term i think this is
quite essential for us to have a wood
chipper so i'm currently looking into
what's the best way
should you have one behind a tractor
like we saw today or a standalone thing
i'm not sure if you have tips let me
know and also if you want to help us out
with this wood chipper make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
so when we could borrow the wood chipper
from the municipality they actually also
said we have a brush cutter which you
can borrow
and i never worked with these things
before but they just seem
like well you guys mentioned it a lot
already on youtube seems very essential
instead of ripping out torns by hand use
one of these machines
i never worked with it before but yeah
today we're gonna give it a test
we currently have a curved plate which
apparently is very good
for chopping thorns and bushes down
so yeah so we have a few areas on the
land that could really use cleaning so
we're going to start off by cleaning
this area
the swamp you've actually seen us
cleaning this a few weeks ago
maybe months but a lot of stuff has
already grown back
so we're gonna chop it down and while
we're at it we're also gonna clean a new
section which we didn't do before
first time
what's up
[Music]
i mean this thing is pretty fast so yeah
just continue
chopping down bushes
[Music]
man this thing is rapid
wow cool let's go to the next one root
so the road on this edges is getting
pretty overgrown especially if you have
a big
van it can be quite tight and scratchy
so yeah let's take them down a bit
so i got kind of excited using this
brush cutter so i figured uh maybe try
out somewhere else
so next to this creek we have a lot like
the whole length of this thing is just
full of thorns and bushes
so i figured let's just have a go with
this thing to see how fast it is
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow that would have taken me so long
to do by hand
and this thing is powerful but now we
can actually see the creek let me show
you
see the trip here it also dropped more
roots here
nice so unfortunately you had to bring
back this tool to the municipality um
and we could borrow it every now and
then but we realized we have 10 hectares
of land
it's a lot to maintain we need to get
one of these things so we actually got
one
and this one is a bit different though
it's an electric powered one
so it makes a bit less noise runs on
batteries so we can charge on solar
uh yeah it's a bit the same with the
chainsaw new technology so i would
maybe make a video about that in the
future on how it actually works you guys
might think are these guys sponsored by
makita no
not at all we used to have power tools
from them and now we can use the same
battery system so we can interchange and
swap
which is nice i do however also have a
lot of mixed feelings about being tied
into a battery system
but yeah anyway special thanks for
everyone supporting on patreon to make
sure we can buy tools like this
so we can move a bit more effective if
you want to help out
uh also on bigger developments like the
wood chipper make sure to visit
support.projectcom.com
[Music]
and last thing the weather has been
really good super sunny super dry so i'm
99.9
sure that next week the containers are
gonna come we've been waiting long for
that moment so if you want to see that
make sure to subscribe so you can see
the
latest video coming up that was it
thanks for watching see you in the next
update